[Music]
Can the Greedo government be destroyed? There's no way
I'm inferior to an artificial government made from a mixture of orichalcum.I
tremble as I like, and that's because some
strong-minded fool tries to put a sword on me at this distance, but
even a piece of sex is gone.  You're such a
scum that you won't even be destroyed by the light of the Granks. This stupid government is your precious government. Pick it up and don't run away. It's still a sage or a buza. What's the matter? It's pathetic. It's a tourist-like dog who starts giving educational guidance.  You
need strict discipline,
right? Stop it, stop it already. Who are you to
say? You've been treating people like crazy, but it's
because of scum like you.
What did you guys do when Roxy-sama helped me and I said that?  It's
Bratty Ptarmigan, I
'll give you status [Music] [Music]
DET